What I'm starting with
I mean this weekend. I'm so
stressed.
I'm I'm stuck
recovering.
Couple of reminders. One is
the final exam Google Sheets spreadsheet
if you can enter
what you're planning to do because you
have three options, right? May 8th, May
12th online or in person. I'm sorry, May
15th online or in person.
It looks like a lot of May 8th and a lot
of
online in New York. And the reason I
bring that up is, you know, if there are
enough people online in New York then I
have a classroom ready to go. So, if
you're online in other country,
obviously you can't be here.
But I prefer if you're here to actually
do it physically in a classroom. It's
easier for you, it's easier for me. So,
you know, I'll
I'll keep you updated
if it turns out that May 8th there are
enough people who are in New York who
want to take it on May 8th then I will
make sure that that will be same 10:00
to 12:00 slot so whatever that slot is.
Nice.
Um the other of course is your project
is due a week from today. So, you know,
you you will continue to get the nagging
emails about the valuation, the pricing
and perhaps for some of you applying
that option pricing model. So, let's
build on that theme of option pricing.
We talked about the three options
embedded in capital budgeting projects.
The option to delay,
the option to expand
and the option to abandon, right? The
option to abandon is unique because it's
a put option. It's the only one of the
real options, it's a put option.
Today I want to talk about two other
options. One in passing
and the other a little more in depth.
The first is an extension of that option
to abandon,
right? You remember the where the value
of the option came from? What does the
option to abandon give you as a company
that makes a project more valuable?
Mitch, you want to try? Limits the
losses. It's It gives you flexibility,
right? Basically, it gives you the
flexibility to essentially get out of an
investment if it doesn't work out. I
want to build on that theme of value
flexibility, adapting to become a big
especially since COVID. We talked about
companies becoming more adaptable and
flexible. Let's use some option language
in the context of capital structure.
Now, most of the options you run into in
capital structure tend to be in how you
structure debt,
right?
We take a fixed income class. Basic
bonds are very simple to value, right?
There's a coupon, there's a maturity,
you take the present value. What makes
bonds complex is if you have caps and
floors and interest rates, whether
they're floating rate bonds or
convertible and most of those things are
option applications.
Okay?
I'm not interested talking about those,
this is not a fixed income class. I want
to talk about another place in capital
structure where flexibility comes up.
Now, some of you are in my corporate
finance class, some of you were in my
corporate finance class last year and
remember we talked about optimal capital
structure?
That a company has a debt rate
Michael, what's the definition of an
optimal debt ratio?
Well, I was going to go with what I
thought you were going at it was where
you want to have a capital structure
where ratings agencies might view it as
one thing when it's really something
else.
And um vice versa, also. That's where
you're taking advantage of ratings
agencies' misconceptions. But
ultimately, forget about the ratings
agencies. When you go out and say, "This
is my optimal debt ratio." what are you
trying to optimize? Cost of capital. You
minimize your cost of capital, right?
It's a very simple process. It's not
rocket science. You can say at 30% at
40% your cost of capital is minimized.
Let's say your company is at a 10% debt
ratio. You come up with an optimal debt
ratio of 30%. This seems like a slam
dunk, right? Just go out and borrow
money. But one of the pushbacks you will
often get is, "We know we have excess
debt capacity, but we don't want to use
it." You say, "Why not?" Cuz we value
financial flexibility. We're holding
that debt capacity just in case we need
it.
So, I want to talk a little bit more
about that because there is an argument
to be made that if you have excess debt
debt capacity that at least at some
companies you don't want to use it up
right now.
The question is flexibility to do what?
So, then what are some of the things you
might want to hold back that capacity
for?
But before that, even if you're a
cyclical company you want to hold it
back just in case there's a recession or
a bad year. But if you're a company
that's ambitious, you want to hold it
back just in case a great investment
comes along. You see how the the mindset
works, right? If there's a great
investment, an acquisition, a big
project, having excess debt capacity is
going to allow us to do that. Therefore,
we're going to hold back. And that seems
like an argument you can't push back
against and often companies use this as
a rationale for not going to their
optimum.
But is that argument So, when you hear
that from a company, are you going to be
okay with that argument? Will it depend
on what the company is or who the
company is?
Mitch, what what kinds of companies
would you not be okay when you hear that
argument you're going to say, "No, I'm
not going to give you that
flexibility."? They have a track record
of doing bad work. Or they're in a bad
business, right? It might not even be
that If you're in a bad business, I
don't want to hear about flexibility to
take good investments because there are
no good investments.
But if you're in a good business, then
I'm willing to listen. But I'm going to
have a follow-up question. In
traditional corporate finance, why do we
not need flexibility?
Because you can always go raise capital
whenever you want. So, the other
question I'm going to ask you is, "Tell
me why you're capital constrained." Cuz
only if you're capital constrained does
flexibility become this additional
amount you want to hold back on.
So, what are some of the reasons a
company might be I knew you were
drinking your coffee. So, what did it
get you just as you got it to your
mouth? What are some of the reasons a
company might be capital constrained?
Where do you usually raise capital from?
External markets, right? So, one might
be
that you're a small company and capital
markets are not you know, amenable to
raising capital.
But if you're a large company, there's
another reason you can be capital
constrained.
If you have to raise equity, what do you
what do you have to do? You have to
issue shares, right? And if you don't
want to issue shares because you don't
like dilution, you might be
self-constrained.
So, the two things that come together
for flexibility to have value is you are
in a good business and you feel you're
capital constrained. So, having this
excess debt capacity allows you to take
those great investments.
So, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
structure that like an option. I'm going
to value it as an option, but it's
really stretching the def the the the
limits of option pricing models. But I'm
going to use the option pricing model to
extract some implications about what
kinds of companies are okay being
under-levered because of this
flexibility and what kinds of companies
you shouldn't allow this as an excuse.
So, here's the structure to think about.
The value of flexibility.
So, let's assume you're a company and
you have some normal reinvestment need
every year,
right? Projects you take every year.
Think of that as your strike price.
If the actual reinvestment needs happen
to exceed those normal reinvestment
needs, having excess debt capacity
allows you to take those projects.
If that never happens,
what did you give up by having excess
debt capacity?
Your cost of capital is higher than it
should be, right? So, in a sense you
said, "I'm okay with a higher cost of
capital." So, that becomes a cost of the
option.
As I said, it's a really messy option to
value, but I'm going to try anyway.
First edition of my Applied Corporate
Finance book came out in 1997. So, I
went back to that edition.
You can get the updated Disney numbers.
Now, it's always been an under-levered
company in all four editions of my book.
First edition, their actual debt ratio
was 18%. Their optimal is 40%. You can
see why. Their cost of capital, which at
their current debt ratio is 12.22% could
become 11.64%
if they go to their optimal.
So, by not being at the optimal, they're
paying 58 basis points more every year
on the cost of capital.
Now, of course, Disney might say, "Look,
we value flexibility."
But, in terms of economics, the value
flexibility has to be greater than 58
basis points a year for this to be okay.
So, I'm going to try to value financial
flexibility on an annual basis.
Here are the inputs I'm going to use.
For the S, which is the actual
reinvestment needs as a percent So, I'm
going to state everything as a
percentage of value because then I can
compare to the 58%.
For the S, which is the actual
reinvestment needs, I went and looked at
the net capex and change in working
capital every year, and I looked at what
that was on average over the last 5
years. It's about 5.3%. So, on average
in a typical year, Disney needs about
5.3% of its value as its reinvestment.
If you look at the variance in that
number, there is a significant amount of
variance.
Yeah, I computed the variance in terms
of natural logs, you'll see this a lot
in option pricing. You know why we use
natural logs in option pricing?
It's built in the Black-Scholes model,
right?
The Black-Scholes model requires a
normal distribution.
Most things are not normally
distributed. Prices, for instance, the
lowest price you can get is zero, the
highest price could be infinity. When
you take a natural log, at least have a
shot of it being normal because the
natural log of zero is minus infinity,
so you get that chance.
So, I took the natural log of the
year-over-year changes. And already you
can see some companies your reinvestment
is pretty level. For Disney, it's pretty
volatile. So, the 0.375 is the standard
deviation of that change.
You can see me trying to bend the
numbers to make it fit my option pricing
model. So, I've got S, I've got sigma.
What's my strike price? It's what Disney
can raise in a typical year from its
internal cash flows, and that's about
4.8%.
I'm going to do this on a on an annual
basis because then I can compare to the
annual cost of not being at the optimal.
So, if I plug the numbers, and as I
said, I'm really stretching the
definitions of option pricing models to
do this,
I come up with
an option pricing value of 1.6092%.
But, that's the value of the option to
take a project.
But, remember, for a project to create
value, what does it have to do?
Earn more than your cost of capital.
This is where being in a bad bad
business or a neutral business is going
to destroy the value of the option,
right? Because I'm going to multiply by
zero. At least in 1997, Disney was
earning an excess return of about 6.47%
over the cost of capital. I'm going to
keep things simple here and assume that
you learn that in perpetuity. That
becomes the net present value of the
projects I take.
You multiply that through, it turns out
that flexibility, at least for Disney,
is worth 0.85%
of value every year.
That's greater than the 0.58%, right?
So, at least for Disney, our argument
would be, let them be. No, they're
under-levered, but it's okay because the
value of flexibility is greater than
what they give up.
Yeah. Previous slide, Yeah. the value
which is for the formula you just
applied that to the asset value market
value of equity. But, so basically, it's
everything is stated in market value
terms because the cost of capital is
market value terms as well.
As I said, don't try this on regular
companies. It's an incredibly messy
process, but even without going through
this model, here are the implications.
The value of financial flexibility
should be greater for companies that are
capital constrained. Remember that K,
what you can raise? If I make that
infinity, in other words, I as much
capacity then the value of the option
goes to zero.
So, more capital constrained companies
should value financial flexibility more
than less capital constrained companies.
Small companies
should value financial flexibility more
than large companies, which means you're
going to let small companies get away
with being under-levered more often than
larger companies, right? A Google or an
Apple have a much greater onus to
justify why they're under-levered than a
small technology company which faces
capital constraints.
Private businesses
will value flexibility more than public
companies. Why? Cuz private businesses
have much more limited access to
capital. They can't go to equity
markets, they can't go to bond markets,
they got to go to the bank to borrow or
raise equity from owners and venture
capitalists.
Companies in emerging markets should
value financial flexibility a great deal
more
than companies in developed markets.
I was in Argentina 2 weeks ago. If
you're in Argentina as a company,
not only do you never want to borrow
money, your debt ratio should go to zero
and lower.
How does your debt ratio get below zero?
What What will they If you value
financial flexibility incredibly high,
not only will you not borrow money, what
will you tend to do?
Have increased income?
You Exactly, you collect cash. You'll
hold cash, and your net debt ratio will
become negative because you value
financial flexibility enough, you're
going to not just not borrow money,
you'll accumulate cash because you value
financial flexibility more.
So, your capital constraints will
determine how much you value financial
flexibility. So, for those of you in my
corporate finance class, that section
right after the optimal debt ratio, it's
a what should the company do now?
These things will come into play, right?
So, if you're under-levered, don't be
too quick to say this company should
borrow more to go to the optimal, take a
look at whether this is the kind of
company where financial flexibility is
valued more.
Second, it should depend on the
unpredictability of your reinvestment
needs, right? If you're a company that
knows exactly how much you're going to
reinvest every year for the next 10
years, the standard deviation in your
reinvestment goes to a zero, the value
of the option disappears as well.
Regulated utilities shouldn't value
financial flexibility very much. They
know what their plans are for the next
decade and longer. A technology company,
we don't know what AI will bring as
reinvestment needs should value
financial flexibility a great deal more.
And finally,
the good business bad business
distinction kicks in.
If you're a company in a good business,
you're in a much better position to
argue that financial flexibility is
worth a lot to you, and therefore you
should be under-levered than you are in
a bad business.
So, as you look across companies, you
can see that some companies you're going
to let go
when they're under-levered because you
say, "These companies have enough value
from financial flexibility that I want
to cut them some slack
because they will need that debt
capacity just in case."
Any questions? Yes, sir. So, maybe a
situation
where where companies just don't have
access to capital.
Companies have access to capital And
that's a good thing, right? Poorly
performing companies shouldn't It's not
poorly performing. Companies that are in
bad businesses have less access to
capital. If you're a poorly performing
company in a good business, I will give
you access to capital, but only if you
tell me you've changed. Which
So, they're
their future in essence? Like, it's
It'll make them make good companies get
larger and small companies get smaller,
which is effectively what we want to
happen
in a capital market, right? I mean, the
key though is if you're a bad company in
a good business, there's still an
opening for you if you can convince me
you've changed, which usually requires a
management change.
Something that tells me that the future
is going to be different. I'm not going
to pump money into a bad business run by
the same management that ran it badly.
Because then there'll be more good money
after bad, right?
Which brings me to the only real option
you're going to be able to apply on your
company.
Let's step back, right? Let's think
about equity in a publicly traded
company. And let's look at what makes
equity equity. First, it's a residual
claim. You get whatever is left over
after everybody else has been covered,
right?
And if you're looking at equity in a
publicly traded company, it comes with
limited liability.
What does that mean?
You can't lose more than you paid for
the shares, right? Your broker can't
call you and say, "The shares are now at
minus 15, please send $15 in."
Those are the two features that are
going to make equity in a publicly
traded company take on the features of a
call option.
Limited liability and the residual
claim. So, let's Let me set up again the
payoff diagram.
For optionality you've got to have some
debt.
So, the face value of the debt becomes
equivalent to the strike price. If the
value of your business exceeds the face
value of the debt, and you decide to
liquidate the business, and this is a
liquidation option,
what do you get as equity investors?
You get the value of the business minus
the face value of the debt, right?
If the value of the business falls below
the face value of the debt, and you
liquidate the business,
limited liability kicks in.
What's the most you can lose? Whatever
you paid for the equity in the company.
I'm going to milk this payoff option to
kind of extract as many implications as
I can about investing in distressed
equities, lending to distressed
companies, because this is equity as a
call option on the entire company.
Don't apply this if you're doing a
private business, and your personal
wealth can be drawn cuz then you you
lose the optionality, right?
So, to set this process up, I'm going to
start with a very simplistic example.
Let's assume I have a business whose
assets are worth a hundred million
today. What am I talking about? If you
liquidated the company today, and you
sold the assets, you get a hundred
million.
But, there's uncertainty about that
number. So, standard deviation in that
value is 40%.
Let's assume that this company has one
10-year zero coupon bond
with a $80 million
face value. In a minute, you're going to
see why I had to make it a zero coupon
bond for the optionality to be easily
valued. One zero coupon bond with an $80
million value. So, let's play it out. If
you liquidate the company today, what
would you have to do? You'd have to sell
the assets, get a hundred million, you'd
have to pay the face value of the debt
off.
You'd have $20 million left over.
The 10-year zero coupon bond though, you
get 10 years to play this game before
you do it. So, just like any other
option, you're not going to liquidate
the you're not going to exercise this
option early. You're going to wait as
long as you can, which means you're
going to wait till the very last day of
the 10th year
to exercise this option.
Finally, let's assume the 10-year bond
rate is 10%.
With those inputs, you should be able to
tell me how much the equity in this
company is worth.
And what interest rate you would charge
on the debt. I haven't given you betas,
cash flows, ratings, nothing.
But I've given you the total value of
the company. Remember this hundred
million,
the value of the company is going to be
split between debt and equity. So, my
question is how much goes to equity, how
much goes to debt. So, I'm going to set
up the option.
Remind me again what the underlying
asset here is.
Value of the firm. That becomes the
underlying asset. The S in the model
becomes a hundred million.
The strike price is if you decide to
liquidate, what happens? You got to pay
the bond, so that becomes a K in the
model, the $80 million.
You got 10 years to play the game, that
becomes the life of the option.
The variance in the value of the
underlying asset, 0.4 squared is 0.16.
And the risk-free rate is 10%. There's
no cost to delay because there's no
early exercise here because you're going
to wait So, this is actually the easiest
of the real options to work because you
don't have to bring in the cost to delay
and dividend yields into the game.
With those inputs put in,
I went through D1, D2,
N of D1, N of D2.
Remind me again what N of D2 roughly
measures. What What do we say N of D2 is
a measure of?
A risk-neutral probability that S will
be greater than K, right?
So, what's S here? The value of the
firm. K is my debt.
There's a 63% chance that the value of
the firm will exceed the value of the
debt.
Or there's a 37% chance of what?
Bankruptcy.
It's a
different way of thinking about the
probability of bankruptcy. 1 - ND2
becomes a rough estimate of the
probability of bankruptcy. There's a San
Francisco-based company called KMV.
It's been around a long time. What banks
can go in their entire business Banks
can bring their loan portfolios into the
company, and KMV lets estimate a
probability of default on the portfolio.
They use an option pricing model. They
use a more refined, more sophisticated
model, but effectively they're doing the
same thing, estimating that ND2,
and 1 - ND2 becomes a So, there's a 37%
chance of bankruptcy. File that away.
Let's work out what the value of the
option is. If you plug in S and K, take
the value to the value of the call
option here is 75.94 million.
That's the value of my equity.
If the value of my equity is 75.94, then
that has to be the remaining 24.
06 million.
It's a zero coupon bond, right? So, my
face value is 80 million, and the
current market value is 24.06 million.
That should be raised to power 1/10, so
just make that a superscript. My
interest rate on my debt
is 12.77%.
That's a default spread of 2.77%.
I I did a review of a paper about 20
years ago where somebody used this to
estimate the probability of default of
companies and compared it to the
probability of default from ratings
agencies ratings. And at least in this
paper, for the sample they looked at,
this gave a better estimate of the
likelihood of default than using a
ratings agency's base rate
or an Altman Z-score
as a predictor of bankruptcy.
So, I've taken the hundred million, I've
split it up between equity 75.94 and
debt of 24.06 million.
So, let's say you make the mistake of
listening to me and paying 75.94 million
for the equity in this company. You're
paying a fair value, right?
Let's suppose tomorrow you wake up to a
catastrophe.
Half your company has disappeared, and
it's not insured.
It's got two factories, one in
California, one in Florida. Take your
pick. Hurricane
or earthquake, one of your factories has
disappeared. Your value of your firm has
halved. Is this good news or bad news to
you as equity investors?
Unless you have a very perverse
definition of good news, this is clearly
bad news.
The value of the firm is halved. I have
a very simple mechanical question.
Remember the value of your equity was
75.94 million before this happened?
You've now lost half the company.
Obviously, the value of equity is going
to drop. My question is by how much? One
is a purely mechanical NPV effect. It's
going to drop by 50 million because
that's what the value of the firm
decreased by.
The second is it will drop by less than
50 million. The third is it will drop by
more than 50 million.
Why? Because your accountants will freak
out after this happens, right? Your book
equity will probably turn negative.
They'll say the company is worth
nothing.
So, 50 million, less than 50 million,
more than 50 million. Gabriel, which one
do you think will happen?
More than
You think more than 50 million?
More than 50.
Oh, it'll be worth more than So, it'll
drop by less than 50 million.
In which case, remember there's a loss
of 50 million, right? So, if you drop by
less than 50 the equity drops by less
than 50 million, somebody else must be
bearing the rest. And who's left to bear
this share?
Bondholders. The lenders will bear it.
Not because they want to, but because
I'm going to drag them in.
So, let's work out what the actual
numbers are because there's an
incredibly useful lesson that comes out
of it. So, I went back to the option
pricing model. What's the only number
that changes? The S, right?
50 million. Everything else stays the
same.
Remember again, 75.94 million. When I
revalued it, it's now worth 30.44
million. It dropped by 45 and a half
million, less than 50 million.
What was my probability of bankruptcy
before?
37%. What's my probability of bankruptcy
now?
59%. Again, makes sense.
The value of my debt goes to 19.456
million, which means if I work out the
imputed interest rate, it's going to be
closer to 14% now.
My equity has become less valuable, my
debt has become riskier, my probability
of bankruptcy has increased.
And it all in a sense makes sense if you
think about the initial start of this
was I lost half my company.
Once I started doing this, I could not
stop myself.
So, I dropped the value of the firm to
40 million, then 30 million, 20 million,
10 million. You know what I was trying
to find out? When does equity become
worthless?
And at least in my case, it hung in
there. When I dropped the value of the
firm, it's an incredibly stubborn
instrument.
The value of the firm equity stayed
afloat even when I dropped the value of
the firm to 5 million and I owed 80
million
on my zero coupon bond.
What's keeping
the value of equity afloat here?
Yes, mate.
What happens if you turn around?
Before you do the turn around, for a
turn around to happen, what else do I
need?
I need time,
and I need hope.
Right?
The 10 years. Something good might
happen, right?
Most of the time when you buy a deep out
of the money option, what's going to
happen to it?
It's going to end up useless, but maybe
that something miraculous will happen
that will make my equity worth.
Some of you have discounted cash flow
valuations, and no matter how hard you
tried,
your equity would not
did not become positive. Why? Because
you owed so much debt that the value of
your
And on a DCF, your conclusion is the
intrinsic value of equity is zero here.
But you can see why you might still
trade this equity, right? It's an out of
the money option. So, Weight Watchers
on an intrinsic value basis is worth
nothing.
But if you want to bet on it as an
option,
there is a framework for thinking
through how much it's worth, and we have
the drivers of the value of the option
right there.
Now, it gave me an entirely new
perspective on what it means to go
bankrupt.
Right? Actually,
my daughter, who turned 30, gave me this
perspective when she was 3 years old.
She's a financial genius.
Not. And So, this was the summer I was
playing Monopoly with my older sons. You
know, she had her two older brothers
there.
And she still has two older brothers, so
No. And she wouldn't She insisted on
joining in.
And she's very persistent, so finally we
let her in. And after a couple of games,
I had to ban her because she was like a
one-person Enron.
Mhm.
She would collect 200 You know how
Monopoly you collect 200 when you pass
go? She would collect 200 for no reason
at all. She'd put hotels on properties
that didn't belong to her, charge you if
you on them. So, finally I said,
"Kendry, you're you're you know, you're
bankrupt."
And she was starts walking around
saying, "You're bankrupt. You're
bankrupt. You're bankrupt." Very
impressed 3-year-old using the word
bankrupt saying, "Kendry, what does
bankrupt mean?" Expecting an answer like
the value of your assets is less than
the value of your outstanding
liabilities. She said, "Bankrupt means
you don't get to play the game anymore."
And you know what? That's a perfect
definition of bankruptcy.
This company is technically bankrupt,
right? At a $5 million value.
But as long as you get to play the game,
the equity is going to hang in there
because there is a chance a tiny chance
it could happen.
And as you get closer and closer to the
end of the 10 years, the value of equity
is obviously going to disappear.
So, you need time
and you need volatility.
Right? You need So, you Here you can see
why when you buy buy distressed equity,
you want to make sure you buy distressed
equity in an extraordinary volatile
firm, not an extremely stable firm.
I don't even know what it means to be a
distressed equity in a really stable
firm. No, I lose 100 million. I can
guarantee I will lose 100 million every
year in perpetuity. That doesn't help
you.
The volatility is what's going to make
the equity valuable.
So, that's the first thing you can see
is equity can hang in even when the firm
is melting down.
Let's take a second place where you can
see this
the real option can give you some
insight.
Now, when we talk about capital
structure and how much you should
borrow, one of the things we talk about
is the interest of equity investors and
the interest of lenders to a firm are
very different. Equity investors want
upside, lenders want to get paid.
And you can use real options to see that
conflict. So, let me go back to the
original example.
Remember the value of the equity was
$75.94 million, the value of the debt
was $44.06 million.
Let's assume that I'm a project sales
person. I show up at your door
with a project to sell you.
You make the mistake of letting me in.
So, I give you the details of the
project and it's a negative net present
value project.
What's your first inclination?
To throw me out, right? I say, "Wait,
wait. Not only is it a negative net
present value project, it's a very risky
negative net present value project."
You feel an even greater urge to throw
me out, right?
Let's say this company goes out
and looks at a project with a net
present value of minus 2 million.
But that the standard deviation of this
project is so high, it'll push up the
standard deviation of the entire firm
to 50%. Is it possible that you as
equity investors could take this project
and actually emerge as winners from this
project?
But I said, "What does it do when you
take a $2 million project at a $100
million value?" What happens when you
take a negative net present value
project? It lowers your value to 98
million. Right? That's bad.
But your standard deviation goes up from
40% to 50%.
Your equity is an option.
Let's see how it plays out. I took my
original
option, I changed the S to 98 million,
and I changed this variance to 0.25.
I want to remember $75.94 million was
the original value. Here's the magic of
optionality. I take a bad project, I
take a very bad risky project,
and what happens to my equity?
It goes up by almost 2 million.
Who's the big loser here?
The debt holders, right? What's the
lesson you take out of this? Never lend
money to a highly distressed company let
the equity investors continue to run the
company.
It's a recipe for disaster
because they're going to transfer wealth
from you. You know, and banks miss this
all the time. They lend money to LBOs
and complain about the fact
that things are not going well for them.
What did you expect?
When you lend to a distressed firm, you
are essentially lending to somebody who
owns an option. And what do option
holders do? They want higher risk.
They're going to go for the higher risk
and if there's enough risk, they might
end up ruining the firm but making
themselves better off in the process.
Yes, sir.
Banks protect themselves by charging
high interest. It won't be enough,
right? You charge a high interest rate.
I can I can meet that and beat that
by transferring enough risk, right? So,
unless you preemptively assume the
maximum risk I can get to and charge the
interest rate that reflects that risk,
you're not going to be able to protect
yourself, right? You need to have a say
in which projects get taken and how I
take projects if it's an incredibly
distressed company, which means you need
people on the board of directors.
You need people actually playing a role
in the management of the company. You
can't be a passive lender to a highly
distressed company and expect not to get
hurt.
Let's talk about a third scenario.
In M&A, and we're going to talk about
this soon, the rule is if you pay fair
value
for a company,
it's a neutral investment. Your equity
should stay unchanged. So, let's assume
this company that we just talked about
with the $100 million value goes out and
acquires another company for a fair
value of 150 million.
Could you as equity investors
be hurt or helped
by an acquisition that's a fair value
acquisition?
Think about it as an option, right?
If you bring two companies together,
remember the two asset portfolio? What
happens to combined companies'
standard deviation or variance?
It'll always go down because as long as
they're not perfectly correlated, two
companies which are imperfectly
correlated, the combined company is
going to get safer.
You see, that's good, right?
It depends. It depends on whether you're
the equity investor or the lender. Let's
play it out. Let's suppose you took two
companies, right? There's my first
company that I just valued. There's a
second company with a $150 million value
with a standard deviation of 50%. I'm
combining the two companies.
Let me throw in the correlation between
the cash flows of those two companies.
They're two different businesses. So,
the combined company has a standard
deviation lower than the standard
deviation of either company.
Classic two asset portfolio which we
begin portfolio theory with.
Play it out now, right? You got a less
risky combined company. If you value the
equity and the debt in the combined
company, the equity in the combined
company is actually about $3 million
lower
than the equity you had in the two
companies going together.
And the lenders gain the 3 million. Why
as a lender
is this merger making you better off?
I don't
And you See, these lenders lent to the
company based on their risk, right? They
set interest rates based on the risk.
The combined company is now safer and
you still get to charge those high
interest rates. That's the $3 million
worth transfer. So, as equity investors,
how do you claw the 3 million back? What
are the two things you can do to claw it
back?
Yes.
One is you retire the existing debt and
raise debt at a lower rate. The other is
when you did the acquisition,
could you have used a lot more debt on
the acquisition?
If you're a conglomerate and you're
building a conglomerate, you should be
using more debt as you build the
conglomerate because if you don't, this
is going to happen at every stage. So,
what do you do? You counter the wealth
transfer by essentially using the safety
to go out and borrow extra money and
driving down the value gain
to the lenders.
Acquisitions at fair value can leave
equity investors worse off if the
combined company becomes safer and
you're still paying bankers the interest
rates you used to pay them
when you were lending to much riskier
companies.
So, real options are useful because they
give you a perspective on things we talk
about in corporate finance but can't put
numbers on. You can see them play out
with real options.
Can you apply this on a real distressed
company? Well, the example I gave you
was incredibly simplistic, right?
I gave you the value of the business up
front. So, somebody must have estimated
the value, but I gave it as the 100
million.
I had one 10-year zero coupon bond.
Why did I make it a zero coupon bond?
What was
It's not just that. What did What
happens as an equity investor? For the
next 10 years, nobody
can come to you with a claim, right?
The zero coupon bond, the entire cash
flow So, the next 10 years, you get
complete freedom
before the whole thing hits you at the
end of the 10th year. In a normal bond,
you don't get that. Every 6 months
there's a coupon due, and if you don't
make that coupon, you could effectively
go bankrupt. The optionality argument
still holds, but you now have 20 options
stacked up on top of each other.
It's not that the option argument fails,
but it becomes a much messier option. In
the real world, if you have a distressed
company, I challenge you to find me a
distressed company that has one nice
zero coupon bond, and that's it.
They're a distressed company. You have
debt from every conceivable source,
right? Because you were desperate.
You have 15 different kinds of debt
with different maturities, different
coupon rates. That's going to be a
challenge.
I gave you the variance in the fame firm
value. You're saying, "How do I get
that?" So, in a sense, all of those
inputs that I gave you in the simplistic
model, if I want to apply this to real
company, I've got to come up with ways
of estimating those numbers.
So, I'll give you some suggestions on
where you can get those numbers. First,
for the value of the firm.
If you've already done your intrinsic
valuation,
you can actually take that value of the
operating assets, make that the S in the
model, right?
With the caveat that this is supposed to
measure liquidation value
of what you would get if you sold the
business today. So, if you're doing an
intrinsic valuation, I'd remove all that
growth stuff if if you have a distressed
company and value the company based on
its existing assets.
So, one way to get your starting point
is to value just the assets place using
a discounted cash flow model and make
that the S in the model.
So, it's not messy in the
discounted cash flow model, go and make
any growth potential go to zero and
essentially value the existing assets in
place.
The second is
if you have assets that are tradeable
assets, real estate, you can just add up
the market values of those pieces of
property and say that's my liquidation
value. So, if seven properties, add up
the value of the properties, becomes the
S in the model.
Or you can even use an enterprise value
multiple to some EBITDA to come up with
So, you need a starting point, get that
point nailed down.
For the variance in firm value, there
are a couple of things you can do. One
is if both the stocks and the bonds in
the company are traded,
you can use their stock prices and
standard deviations and compute the
variance in firm value by taking a
weighted average.
The only you know, it's it's a messy
process because distressed companies,
the equity and debt take on some very
strange characteristics.
So, I almost never do that because the
alternative is much simpler. You have a
distressed steel company,
go to the
industry average variances for steel
companies and use that as a variance for
your company. It's just like we look up
betas for businesses, you can look up
standard deviations. There's a There's a
spreadsheet that I have on my webpage
that gives you variances in firm value
by industry and that's designed
specifically for real options. And my
advice is if your company is one of
those companies that becomes is meets a
distressed equity test, use that variant
because it's actually a better estimate
of variant than trying to get out of the
company numbers.
That's the variance in firm value. For
the value of the debt, I'm going to
cheat. And here's what I mean by
cheating. I'm going to take a 15
different debt issues
and I'm going to try to replace them
with one zero coupon bond of equivalent
value.
So, I'll take a the face value of all
your debt, including interest payments,
add them all up, come up with a total
number, and then I'll take a weighted
average of the maturities and treat that
as the duration of the bond. It's
cheating,
but it makes my life simpler.
If I can do all of that stuff, I can
value the equity
in distressed equity
in any company. So, let me try this out.
I mean, it's a very old example, but
I've stuck with it because it kind of
resonates.
This company called Eurotunnel. What
does it do? It's a hole in the ground
which cash goes in but never seems to
come out.
So, a tunnel that connects
the UK to France. And essentially,
originally it was built because both
governments thought they could make
money
from the Eurotunnel. It's never really
made money. It's never been able to get
its head above water.
So, at the time that I did this,
Eurotunnel had earnings before interest
and taxes of 56 million pounds, a net
income of minus 685 million pounds.
We'll talk about why the difference
between the operating loss and the net
loss is so great, but it's a
money-losing company.
To add fuel to the fire, its book value
of equity had become negative. Why?
Because it had lost money for so long,
the book value of equity had been
completely wiped out.
So, it met one of the the the first of
the two conditions, the money-losing
company with no end in sight in the near
term.
The other requirement for a distressed
equity option is that it has to be debt.
This company has a boatload of debt. In
fact, it has almost 9 billion pounds in
debt,
a lot of it long term.
And you see with the option pricing why
that matters, right? Because the longer
the maturity, the more life there is in
the option. So, I took a weighted
average of the duration of all of the
debt issues. So, here's what I'm going
to do. I'm going to take all of this
messy debt and replace it with one zero
coupon bond with a face value of 8.865
billion and a 10.93
year duration. So, it's starting to look
like my simplistic example, right?
What's the one number that's not there?
I haven't given you the value of the
firm.
So, I did a traditional discounted cash
flow model,
but I kept everything muted, no high
growth. Basically, I assumed that they
would fix themselves over time in terms
of operating losses, turn the corner,
become reasonably profitable.
And with my upbeat optimistic story, the
value that I got for the firm with these
assumptions that over time the margins
would improve, the you know, the cost of
goods sold would drop, the capital
spending would grow at the same rate as
revenues, the value that I got for the
firm was 2.3 billion pounds. Remind me
again how much they owe?
Almost 9 billion.
And my S is 2.3 billion.
This is insanity, right? You're saying,
why would I buy equity in the company?
Why might you buy equity in the company?
Because the debt is really long term
and you're hoping that something good
will happen.
What might that be? The Sultan of Brunei
says, "Look, I'd like my name on the
tunnel. I'll pay 15 billion dollars."
It's a reach,
but you have a long time period going
for you.
So, here's what I The The final input I
needed was a variance, and here I did
not have an industry average variance
because it was a fairly unique company.
So, I stayed with the stocks and the
bonds issued by the company, they were
both traded. The standard deviation in
stock prices was about 41%. The standard
deviation in bond prices was about 17%.
And because they were both traded, I
could also compute the correlation
between the two. And the correlation
that I got between the two is about 0.5.
The bonds and the stocks tended to move
together a fair amount.
It's mostly debt It's a debt-funded
company, 85% debt, 55% 15% equity. If
this equation looks unfamiliar, it's
just the two-asset portfolio, stocks,
bonds, and the covariance term.
The variance in firm value
for Eurotunnel is about 0.0335.
And remember what I said about
variances, they will look low because
they're standard deviation squared.
That's going to become the variance that
drives value of my option.
I pretty much everything I need
to value the option. Here's what the
inputs look like. 2.3 billion pounds is
the equivalent of the S in the model.
So, in my simplistic example, the 100
million is now the DCF value, 2.3
billion.
The K in the model is the total value of
the debt outstanding, that nine almost
8.9 billion pounds, that becomes the K
in the model.
The T in the model is the weighted
average duration of my debt, 10.93
years. And for the variance in the
previous page,
it's 0.0335.
Now, in option pricing, your risk-free
rate should always match the life of
your option, so I've kind of kept that
going.
Risk-free rate is 6%.
D1, D2, N of D1, N of D2. What's the
probability that Eurotunnel will go
bankrupt?
92%.
No surprise here. It's a basket case
company.
But here's the miracle. You have a
company where the value of the business
is 2.3 billion, it owes almost 9
billion,
but because you have time and risk on
your side, the value of the option, the
value of the call option I get is 122
million pounds.
No intrinsic value model would have
worked here
because no matter what I did, I would
have got a value for the assets less
than the outstanding debt.
Could I have tried pricing pricing or
what? No, there are no earnings. I could
try revenue multiples, but even with
that, I would have got a value less than
the debt.
Some of you are in the same position.
Who's valuing Weight Watchers?
Somebody's valuing
Your DCF value, remember what you did?
Negative, right? The value of the firm.
You try pricing, my guess is all the
pricing is giving you numbers less than
the debt.
This might be your only way of actually
eking out some some value is you're
buying it as an option. So, what will it
depend on?
How long term your debt is, right? I'm
not sure what it is for Weight Watchers,
but if it's three months debt, you're
done. You're You're You're sunk. If you
have three year or five year or 10 year
debt, maybe there is some optionality
where you sit and hope that the
restructuring pays off or somebody will
pay for the the brand, the the the They
also have that license to Probably we We
go being a subject to something. There's
a small chance of it happening, but
you're buying it for the same reasons
you're buying a deep out of the money
option.
You heard of vulture investing?
What What do vulture investors do?
They buy troubled companies, right? They
buy equity in troubled companies.
They're basically buying deep out of the
money options.
If you look at a vulture investor's
portfolio, they If you invest in 100
deep out of the money options, even if
you're a good vulture investor, you know
what you're going to see? 80% of what
they invest in will go to zero.
You're saying, "How the heck do they
make money?" The 20% that doesn't go to
zero comes with 5,000, 10,000, 15,000%
returns, and hopefully it makes up for
all those investments you had to wipe
out. It's a very different mindset,
right?
You don't go in with the value investing
mindset that I want to win 60% of the
time. If you win 10% of the time and you
win big,
it's going to cover the 90% of the time
that you lose money.
Cuz you're buying a whole host of deep
out of the money options.
So, latch on to a Weight Watchers or
some other distressed company, track its
equity for a while because you get
you'll start to get a sense of what it
is that drives it.
So, to close up my real options
discussion, there are real options
everywhere.
But, most of them
don't have much economic value. Why?
Because they're not exclusive.
So, much of what people talk about AI,
you can argue is an option, but most of
those options are not valuable because
there's no exclusivity in that.
And if there's exclusivity, you're
pushing the limits of option pricing
models.
So, it's not what you get out of option
pricing models, it's the mindset that
comes from looking at something as an
option. That risk is now your ally, the
way you think about the investment
changes that I hope you can get out of
real options.
So, the next time you hear the words
flexible, adaptable, consulting firms
use them, there's an optionality
argument there.
And those are the things you're trying
to do when you bring real options into
the discussion.
Any questions about real options in
general?
A few years ago, student of mine who
started organizing these valuation
seminars all over the country called me
and he says his valuation seminars were
about acquisitions. They were directed
at serial acquirers, which are companies
that do an acquisition of the month
club.
And
so, he said, "Well, we're gathering a
lot of CFOs of serial acquirers in New
York. Would you be willing to come in
and talk to them?"
And I said, "Are you sure you've got the
right guy?
You know what I think about
acquisitions, right?" He said, "No, I
know exactly what you think about
acquisitions, but they're going to be
hearing from the rest of the day from
M&A bankers. You know what M&A bankers
think about acquisitions, right?"
It's the greatest thing ever.
He said, "Can you come in the last 30
minutes to give an antidote?" And I
said, "Sure." And I came in and put the
first slide up. It kind of gave away
what I thought about acquisitions.
Acquirers Anonymous, seven steps to
sobriety.
Cuz I think acquisitions are an
addiction.
Cuz once a company starts to grow
through acquisitions, it's so difficult
to go back to taking individual
projects.
How many of you are planning to work in
M&A?
Right.
I'm going to put up seven tests, and I'd
like to make a deal with you. If you
fail more than two of those seven tests,
I'd like you to reconsider.
I know it's late in the process. I'm
sure you will pass the test, you know.
So,
I'm going to start with some bare facts
as to why I'm so skeptical about
acquisitions as a process.
There are two gay two players in an
acquisition, right? That the acquirer
and the target company.
This graph, I have the on average what
happens to stock price of the acquiring
company, that's the red line, and on
average what happens to the stock price
of the acquiring company. It's no
contest.
The winner here are the shareholders in
the target company, and the losers tend
to be the shareholders in the acquiring
company.
At least on average,
target company shareholders win,
acquiring companies are either neutral
or hurt by acquisitions.
In fact, on the initial announcement of
an acquisition, in 55% of the cases, the
acquiring company's stock price drops
when it announces an acquisition, which
tells you that markets don't believe all
the synergy and all the great stories
being told. They believe that it's going
to leave you worse off, your
shareholders worse off than before.
Now, if you present this to M&A people,
of course their argument is,
"Markets don't know what we do."
Right? They They haven't seen our
synergy projections, all this neat stuff
we've looked at. And on the face of it,
that's true, right? Markets don't have
access to the information that the
managers in the firm firms do.
So, here's a follow-up.
There are studies that have looked at
mergers 5 years or 10 years after the
merger happens to assess whether in fact
synergy shows up.
And whether these acquisitions deliver
what they promised at the outset.
McKinsey's been doing these studies for
30 years, and they ask very very basic
questions. They ask, "Does the return on
capital on an acquisition exceed the
cost of capital, including the synergies
and all the good stuff?" Cuz that's the
test we apply on any exercise.
Does Does an acquisition help a company
do better than the peer group? Because
often that's the story you're told,
right? If we do an acquisition, we'll
become much better than the peer group.
And they found that in half of all the
companies they looked at,
they either failed one test or in some
cases both tests.
KPMG did a study of all M&A deals done
over a 4-year or 5-year period,
thousands and thousands of deals. And in
83% of the cases they looked at, there
was no synergy
or reverse synergy.
So, when you look at actual deals, there
is evidence both at the time of the
announcement and if you follow up that
most deals don't work.
And what makes this worse is we've known
this for 40 years, and nothing seems to
change.
Right?
Which tells you what? That there's
something broken in the process that's
leading a lot of bad deals to go
through. And by now, we've talked about
what in the process causes the bias we
talked about early on, I think pushes
this process.
Now, what I think makes this um more
dangerous is this disease is spreading.
What do I mean by that? For a long time,
you're in emerging market company,
you're usually the target in
acquisitions.
About 20 years ago, this process started
to turn because emerging market
companies started to become valuable
enough that they started acquiring
developed market companies.
Remember when it first started happening
with Indian companies,
there was a patriotic
cheering of, "Finally, we're acquiring
companies. We're big enough that we can
go acquire UK companies and US
companies."
This study looked at what happens at
Indian companies when they do
acquisitions.
Guess what? When the initial acquisition
is announced at the point zero, there is
some celebration. The stock prices go
up, but by the time you get to about a
year after the acquisition,
the hangover has set in. So, 15, 16, 17
months later, you look at the stock
price of acquiring companies in India,
they exhibit the same phenomena you see
at US companies.
There's a collective after-the-fact
realization that much of what was
promised was not delivered.
So, you can slice this and dice this and
start look for good news, and we will
talk about some some aspects of
acquisitions that have delivered value,
but on average,
acquisitions have destroyed more value
than they've ever created.
So, we'll talk about we'll we'll talk
about the specifics, but you know, if I
were to draw a conclusion based on all
these studies, acquiring companies pay
too much up front for target companies.
They promise too much in synergy, which
is actually not delivered.
And there's something in the process
that allows this to continue over and
over again without ever getting fixed.
Okay?
There's bias in the process that seems
not clear.
So, I'm going to put you through seven
tests on acquisitions.
And I think by this time in this class,
you should be able to pass all seven.
Let's see what these seven issues
The first is what I call risk transfers,
which is acquiring companies when they
look at target companies,
think they can make a target company
safer just because they're safer as
acquiring companies. We'll talk about
how this plays out in discount rates.
Second is what I call debt subsidies.
An acquiring company's access to cheap
debt, they use that cheap debt to buy a
target company, they pay a premium.
You're effectively subsidizing the
shareholders
of the target company.
The third is control. Remember the 20%?
It's kind of built into the acquisition
process. We're going to talk about the
true value of control and why 20% might
not be the right indicator to use for
that.
On synergy, I'm willing to keep the door
open. There are synergies. We'll talk
about how to value them, but in most
acquisitions, people don't value
synergy.
What they use it as is a plug variable.
You know what I mean by plug variable?
It's whatever they they use it to
justify whatever premium they pay. 30,
50, you can Whatever the premium, it's
justified by synergy.
The fifth is pricing
in acquisitions.
We'll talk about the statistical
problems you run into when people price
companies for acquisitions, in the way
they create the peer groups and the
multiples that they use in pricing those
companies.
Sixth step, and this may be the core
problem, is in many acquisitions, the
verdict gets made gets made first by
somebody way up, and your job lower down
the ranks is to justify what the CEO and
the top management's already decided to
do.
And finally, and I think this is a big
part of the problem, is there's no
accountability.
Which is when you screw up, nobody seems
to be at fault.
You can make a $10 million mistake on a
project, and you get fired. You make a
$10 million mistake on an acquisition,
you get promoted.
There's no justice in this world.
So, with each one, I'm going to take a
very simple example to illustrate it. I
want you to keep a running tab. You
don't have to tell me of whether you
passed the test or failed the test. So,
this is your page.
Now, I won't look at it. You can be
honest with yourself or dishonest. I
really don't care. You can fix things if
they're not right.
So, I'm going to take through a series
of tests and for these tests you don't
need a calculator. I'm going to take a
very simple example to kind of
illustrate each step in the process.
So, let's start with a target company.
I'm going to play the role of trying to
sell you this target company for more
than you should be paying for it.
Let's see if you fall for my pitches,
right?
So, here's what the target company looks
like. It's got revenues of 100 million,
operating income pre-tax operating
income 20 million, and after-tax
operating income of 12 million.
It has zero growth in perpetuity. And
there's a reason I'm making it zero
growth is to make your life easier.
It's all equity funded and its cost of
equity is 20%.
What is the value of this target
company?
How do you get 60 million? I didn't give
you any numbers for the cash flows. What
is it about the problem that allowed you
to come up with the cash flow?
It is that the growth rate
is zero, right? The growth rate is zero.
I don't need reinvestment. There's no
reinvestment. After-tax operating income
becomes free cash flow to the firm.
And because you've known that, I can
discount it back at the 20%. So, 12
million divided by 0.2 is 60 million.
Everybody with me so far?
What's my job? Is to try to get you to
pay more than 60 million. So, here's my
first try.
Your cost of equity of the acquiring
firm is 10%.
They come to you and say, "Look,
this firm should be worth a lot more to
you."
You see how you know the the argument
I'm making, right? 12 million is your
cash flow. Your cost of equity is 10%.
Would you be willing to pay
100 and what what does it work out to?
12 120 million?
Why not, Dakshesh?
We learned in We learned this in one of
the first classes that you do not
Don't tell me what you learned. Tell me
the rationale, the logic as to why the
acquiring company can't use its cost of
equity to value the target company. The
target is riskier and acquiring
company's shareholder won't just settle
for 10%.
Yes. Aren't you
essentially looking at the value of that
company independently and then
back to capital budgeting, right? What's
the rule in capital budgeting? The
discount rate for a project should
reflect the risk of the project, right?
It's an extension of the same principle.
So, value of a target company, looking
at the cash flows of the target company,
the discount rate that should be using
should be the discount rate that
reflects the risk of the target company.
The fact that you're a nice safe
acquiring company means absolutely
nothing in this context. It doesn't even
come into play.
Half of all M&A acquisition valuations I
see you use the acquiring company's cost
of capital or cost of equity to value
the target company.
And it's part of the reason is we call
it cost of capital, right? When you
think of cost of capital, what do you
think of? It's a cost of raising money.
But the cost of capital in a discounted
cash flow valuation is an opportunity
cost based on the risk. Yes.
Wouldn't you argue that the reason that
they're using the
acquiring company's cost of capital
not as much because it's based on the
intrinsic valuation of that project or
company, but
bankers report that I'm going to price
to it and making sure that price
Maybe that do you go through, but I
would love to say that that's the
devious reason they're using it. I don't
think it's that devious. They just don't
get what a cost of capital is. They
think it's a cost of raising money
rather than an opportunity cost, right?
But you might be right. It might be that
they know that they're doing the wrong
thing, but they do it because they want
the deal to be done.
But my No, the amount of
misunderstanding people have about what
a cost of capital is
runs deep and I think that plays out
here.
So, everybody agree? You can You're
stuck at 60 million, right?
So, this didn't work. I'm going to try a
second ploy.
You know, so the let's summarize that.
If if you're looking at any acquisition,
the discount rate for valuing a target
company should always be based on the
target company unlevered beta of the
target company, not the unlevered beta
of the acquiring company. It doesn't
come into play. Because if you don't do
that, I'll safely predict what's going
to happen over time. You're a safe
company, what are you going to end up
doing? Buying a lot of risky companies
think thinking they're cheap. And the
end of the process you're going to say,
"Oh my god, we became a risky business
without
essentially doing all the hard work of
building a risky business." That's how
AT&T almost destroyed its value in the
1990s is by buying company after company
thinking these companies were cheap.
I remember visiting GE, you know,
long time ago when they had their
headquarters in Stamford. It's a company
at that time at the peak of its its at
its you know,
top market cap pretty much towards the
top. And the company that grew through
acquisitions and you think that a
company like GE would do the right
thing. They had a corporate finance
department incredibly sophisticated.
They were buying target companies based
on GE's cost of capital.
Okay?
And their reaction was these companies
are so small, we're so big, what
difference does it make?
The promise is you make No, you can
argue about averaging out a mistake, but
that's not going to happen here, right?
Because you're going to overpay on every
single mistake. It's all going to add
up.
So, let me try a second ploy to try to
get you to pay more. Let's say you're a
triple-A rated company.
You're the acquiring company and you
have access to cheap debt at 4% after
taxes.
And you also have excess debt capacity.
Why? Cuz you built up debt capacity over
time as an acquiring company.
And you decide to fund this acquisition
with 50% debt and 50% equity. Let's
forget about levering and unlevering
betas. Let's leave the cost of equity at
20%.
If I just go through the mechanics of
cost of capital,
what's the cost of capital for this
target company now going to be?
50% * 20% equity + 50% * 4% debt, which
will give me a 12% cost of capital. 12%
cost of capital will translate into a
100 million dollar value.
You guys okay with that? You pay 100
million dollars for the company because
you have access to cheap debt.
This sounds like it's more sellable than
the first one, right?
But Michael, what will happen if you do
this?
Well, it's going to be a riskier
business.
It's not necessarily You paid me the 100
million. You paid me a 40 million dollar
premium, right? Where did the 40 million
premium come from? From the fact that
you're a really safe company and you
were careful about how much you borrowed
for the last century.
I mean, there's a rule in acquisitions,
render unto the target company that
which is theirs and not a dollar more.
I had nothing to do with you getting the
great rating or having debt capacity.
You paid me the 40 million.
You're essentially paying target company
shareholders for something that they're
zero role in creating. You say, "But I
have excess debt capacity." You're
right, you have excess debt capacity. Go
out and buy back stock if you want to.
You don't have to buy a target company
and pay a premium to get there.
So, even though you have cheap debt,
you know how this plays out, right? When
you do a cost of capital of a target
company, never use the actual debt and
equity mix used to fund that target
company.
Why? Because I could use 100% debt if
I'm a big company to do an acquisition,
I can use 100% debt. And I've seen
people use the cost of debt as their
cost of capital
when they value these target companies,
which causes the value of the target
company to explode into this huge
number.
And they're paying a premium for again
something that the target company had
zero role in creating.
Yes. But then that would let us split
50/50, right? They talk about the EPS
accretion entire We'll talk about that,
why that's it's kind of irrelevant here,
right? EPS accre- accretion creates no
value. It just No, something that's
always going to be created when you
borrow money to do an acquisition. It's
ac- actually no relevance to whether a
deal is a good deal or a bad deal, even
though bankers might use it. No.
Yes. Do you think of that about it as
value transferred from bond bond holders
to From the shareholders because the
because this was excess debt capacity.
So, the acquiring company could have
used it to take a project, could have
used it to buy back stock. They used it
to overpay on a target company. The key
word is overpay. So,
as a shareholder I have mixed feelings.
You used my debt capacity, that's good.
But then you overpaid 40 million, which
means those target company shareholders
walked away with the benefits of you
using my debt capacity.
Control, right?
You know that envelope I held, control
and as to how much you pay for a $20
bill.
But this is embedded in M&A, 20% control
premiums.
Right?
So, I come to you now because you didn't
fall for my trying to get you to use
your cost of equity, didn't fall for me
trying to get you to use your low cost
debt and debt capacity. So, I say, "Hey,
what about a 20% premium?" That's
another 12 million on top of 60 million.
And my response is everybody does it. If
you have to do an acquisition, you have
to pay a control premium.
We've kind of laid the foundations for
it.
Where does control Where does the value
of control come from?
Did you think you can run a company
differently, better than the existing
management run, right? Is that possible
in a target company? Absolutely. Maybe
they're taking bad projects. Maybe
they're not reinvesting enough. Maybe
they're reinvesting too much. Maybe
they're not using enough debt.
But to do this right, what do you have
to do? You have to value the company
twice.
You got to value the company as is, the
status quo, and value of the company run
optimally. And that difference
is the value of control, right?
So, let's take this example, you know,
if you look at this this target company,
$12 million in after-tax operating
income, let's assume that if you ran the
company, you could raise that to 15
million. Why? Cuz you're really good at
cutting costs and keeping them
controlled.
So, the 60 million becomes 75 million,
right?
Would you pay the extra 15 million to
the target company in acquiring this
company?
If you did, what have you effectively
done? You're going to do the dirty work
of fixing the company,
and who's getting the benefits?
Target company shareholders. So, if
you're
creating control and creating control
value, you want to negotiate for some of
that because you're the one doing the
cost cutting, right? If you paid all up
front, see, what it always comes back
to, what is the price you're paying?
Even if there's control, if you pay the
entire control up front as part of the
price,
you're you're effectively going to earn
the cost of capital. It becomes a
neutral investment.
So, with control, I have no problem with
you with you bringing control in, but
you can't add an extra 20% or 50%. It
depends on the target company. It
depends on how well or badly it's run,
and depends on what changes you think
you can make in this company. You got to
be realistic about what those changes
are.
So, 20% control premiums, it could be
15, it could be 50, it could be 100, it
could be zero, depending on the target
company.
Synergy, right?
I gave you the my definition of synergy,
right? Do you remember what it was?
What's the essence of synergy?
First, you need two entities, right?
Synergy can't exist on its own.
And what is synergy
measured? Measures what the two entities
brought together can do as a combined
entity that they could not have done.
Keyword is could not have done as
stand-alone entities.
Okay.
People often mix up control and synergy.
I'll often hear bankers say, "There's
synergy in this acquisition because I
can run the target company more
efficiently." And I say, "No, no, that's
control. Let's do that separately cuz
the way you negotiate for control has to
be very different from the way you
negotiate for synergy."
So, let's talk about about about about
synergy, and I'll set up some very
simplistic examples. Let's assume you're
told that the combined firm will be less
risky than the two individual firms, and
therefore because it's less risky,
it should be more valuable. This was at
the heart of the conglomerate
build-up through the '70s.
What is it about the way we've done
intrinsic valuation that rules out that
possibility?
You're two publicly traded companies.
How do we get the cost of equity?
We got the beta, which measures what?
The risk you cannot diversify away.
Okay. The risk that's going to go away
when you combine two companies is the
company-specific risk, and if it's not
in your cost of equity,
combining the two companies cannot
create any value.
A little later in this session on on
Wednesday, I'm going to talk about why
in private company
deals, you can sometimes create value.
Do you see why?
Private companies, what do we use to get
the cost of equity?
A total beta. Total beta looks at total
risk. There, you can make the risk
argument of that a combined company will
be less risky, it'll have a lower cost
of capital. Public so, that argument
doesn't get very far.
What if I told you there was potential
growth that you can get as a combined
company?
Feasible, right? What do I have to do? I
have to take the combined company and
tell you where the additional growth is
coming from and how much it's worth.
Or it can be cost savings.
Cost savings will show up as lower
costs, higher margins, and higher value.
I'm not saying synergy doesn't exist,
but you got to try to value it if you're
going to pay a premium. But let's say
you value that synergy, and again, we
get back to the same question. You pay
that up front
as a premium.
Everything is tilted in favor of the
target company shareholders, right? They
walk away with all the winnings. You're
doing the dirty work of creating
control, you know, creating synergy, and
none of it accrues to your shareholders.
Why? Because we haven't valued it. How
the heck are you going to negotiate for
a share of it?
And that's why I think we need to pay
more attention to valuing control and
valuing synergy because you're going to
try to get a share of that for your
shareholders.
So, I'm going to set up a structure for
valuing synergy.
Synergy, broadly speaking,
can take one of two forms. It can be
operating synergy.
Operating synergy can take the form of
economies of scale.
Two companies in the same business
coming together. Two steel companies,
two chemical companies come together,
they have some overlapping costs, they
cut back the costs. Cost savings,
easiest of all synergies to value
because
you reduce the cost, increase the margin
of the combined company, and you're
done.
Or it can be growth synergies. Growth
synergies can take the form of either
higher returns on your new investments
as a combined company because you will
increase your competitive advantages.
It can take the form of more new
investments, a higher reinvestment rate.
Or it can even take the form of more
sustainable excess returns because you
built a barrier to entry.
See, I'm trying to bring it into an
input in valuation, right? More
sustainable excess excess returns mean a
longer growth period. Higher returns on
capital translate into a higher growth,
more projects, higher reinvestment rate.
So, that's operating synergies. I'd love
to tell you that much of the synergy in
in mergers comes from operating
synergies, but it doesn't.
Much of the synergy in mergers comes
from or financials I'll call it
financial synergy. And the most common
form of financial synergy is the one you
should never talk about if it's the
reason for your merger.
Taxes.
If you're doing a merger for tax
reasons, talk about everything but
taxes.
Talk about this is a great point to open
up your strategy book and start throwing
buzzwords. We're doing this for
strategic reasons, you know.
Why? Because the minute you mention that
your merger is driven primarily by
taxes, like waving a red flag in front
of the tax guy saying, "Come and get
me."
Let's take Let's take a look at the
different ways in which tax synergies
can show up.
In some mergers, after the fact,
you know, you get accounting firms to
come in and write up your assets to fair
value.
One of the advantages you get from
writing up assets, your depreciation
following time periods can be higher.
Higher depreciation, higher tax
benefits. You have a money-losing
company and a money-making company come
together, especially the money-losing
company comes with lots of NOLs,
the combined company benefits because
those NOLs can now be used much more
quickly and much more certainly.
And there are parts of the world where
the there are quirks in the tax code
that actually help you when you do when
you do mergers.
In Brazil, there is this item called
interest on capital,
where companies are allowed to claim a
deduction based on the book equity. They
can take the book equity and multiply it
by a rate that the government gives, 11%
this year. 11% of book equity is
subtracted out just like interest
expenses.
It was the Brazilian government's
attempt to bring debt and equity the
same tax advantages.
But in a merger, here's how it plays
out. You do a merger, your book equity
gets written up
cuz you combined two companies, because
the goodwill is now part of your book
equity. You multiply that higher book
equity by 11%,
you get a much bigger deduction for
taxes,
and that can be billions of dollars.
So, those are tax reasons for synergies.
Sometimes, you can have two companies
that by standing alone can't borrow much
money. It's not that they don't want to,
but they just can't. They're they're
small, they can't carry more than 10%
debt ratios. But as a combined company,
they get safer, they might be able to
borrow at 20% debt ratio. That pushes up
the value, lowers the cost of capital.
It's kind of a tax reason again through
the debt.
And finally, private companies are the
only exception to the rule that
diversification should never be used as
a reason for mergers. With public
companies,
why is diversification a bad reason for
for for doing mergers?
It doesn't even have to be a merger. You
and I can do with a diversification. It
costs me And none of us pays a 20%
premium on the market price. If any of
you're doing it, I'd be willing to be a
broker, right?
We pay market price. When you do a
merger, you got to pay a 20% premium.
But private businesses, you can see why
combining two companies, diversification
can make you
more valuable. Where does it show up in
in your inputs in valuing a private
company?
The correlation becomes higher with the
market. The correlation becomes higher,
your total beta decreases. It's almost
like you get an overnight jump in value.
So, when you value synergy, it's a
three-step process.
To value synergy, you first have to
value the target company and the
acquiring company as stand-alone
companies.
You know how you can tell when bankers
haven't even tried to value synergy?
Is the acquiring company never even
enters the script. It's all with the
target company. You cannot value synergy
by just looking at the target company.
You've got to bring the acquiring
company into the mix.
That's step one. Value the two companies
as stand-alone companies.
Next step, just add the two values up.
Values are additive. If there were no
synergy, the combined value for the
company should be the sum of the two
values.
In step three, take the combined
company, throw all of the synergies you
think will show up, and value the
combined company with the synergies
built in.
3 - 2
will give you the value of synergy.
The value of the combined company with
the synergies minus the value of the
independent company.
So, I'm going to leave you with an
example. This is from way back in time,
one of the largest mergers when it
happened.
Procter & Gamble, largest consumer
product company in the world there,
bought Gillette, the fifth largest
consumer product company in the world.
Talk of synergy filled the air. I tried
to do a best-case valuation of synergy,
and I'll explain why I call it best
case.
I called the combined company Piglet.
Now, they preferred to keep it as, you
know, I thought P&G Gillette would have
Now, they stayed with P&G as the
combined company. But, if you look at
the third column, that is basically just
the sum of the two companies put
together,
and the value of the combined the
company standing alone put together is
281 billion. So, that's just the value
of the companies with no synergy.
Then, I took what managers told me they
would pull off as synergy and assumed it
would happen instantaneously.
Now, do you see why this is best case,
right?
Most of the time when managers talk
about synergies, they never show up, or
if they show up, they show up 5 years
later. Here, it's happening
instantaneously. They talked about
cutting operating expenses by 250 mil. I
assumed next year they would cut
expenses by 250 mil. That increases
their operating income.
They talked about increasing the growth
rate. I assumed it would happen right
away.
You think, why only a 1% increase in
growth rate? Two large companies in the
consumer product business, you're not
going to jump your growth rate by 10 or
15%.
With those changes put in, the value
that I got for the combined company was
298 billion.
The difference between that and that,
17.2 billion, is the value of synergy.
This is a great merger, right? What have
I not told you though to
to judge this merger?
What they paid as a premium. They paid a
$25 billion premium
for Gillette, and therein lies the
problem with M&A.
You pay $25 billion
for a best-case valuation of 17.2
billion. How the heck do you walk away
from this process
as a winner?
So, next class when we start when we
start, I'm going to you know, take a
little more involved example of synergy,
InBev and SABMiller,
and use it to talk about, you know,
the messiness of valuing synergy. But,
you got to kind of you have the
foundations in place at least of
thinking about M&A deals and how to take
them apart in terms of control and
synergy.
So, I'll see you on Wednesday.